الى ملفيه حربي روسي على اوكرانيا حيث
قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه خرسون
جنوبيه البلاد انها بدات اجلاء المرضى من
مستشفيات المقاطعه الى مقاطعه اكثر امنا
وفي حين تصاعد القصف الروسي على منطقه
خرسون قال الجيش الاوكراني ان عددا من
القرى في المقاطعه تتعرضوا لقصف روسي
متواصل وقالت السلطات الاوكرانيه ان
البنيه تحتيه تضررت بشكل كبير لدرجه ان
الحكومه نصحت المواطنين بمغادره المنطقه
ذكرت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها
صدت ثماني محاوله روسيه لتقدم في مقاطعه
دونيست بعد خسائر كبيره تكبدتها الوحدات
الروسيه في
لوغانسكوا في قصفا روسي استهدف العديده من
مدن وبلدات المقاطعه خلال الساعات الماضيه
ونقل مراسلنا في اكرام تورس كان قصفا
عنيفا لستادف المدينه مساء امس ادى لتدمير
مبنيين وتضرري عدد من المنازل القديمه
بشان استهداف المدنيين وعدم الرغبه في
تسويه السلميه
الجزيره المعتز بالله حسن المعتز في هذا
الطقس البارد
ما الذي تقوله السلطات الاوكرانيه عن قصف
روسيا للبنى التحتيه والنقص في امدادات
الطاقه
في هذا الطقس البارد محمد تقول السلطات
الاوكرانيه انها تعمل ما في جهدها لاعاده
الكهرباء الى جميع المشتركين محمد هنا
التدفئه حتى التدفئه هي على الكهرباء
وبالتالي يمكنك ان تتخيل ان انقطاع
الكهرباء في بلد مثل اوكرانيا وعاصمه
متلكيه ما الذي يمكن ان يفعله بالسكان
وبالتالي هي تسعى لاعاده الكهرباء والطاقه
الى جميع المواطنين خصوصا وانا تصريحات
الرئيس الاوكراني همم
تتحدث عن انه ما زاله هناك مشتركون لم تصل
لهم الكهرباء حوالي 600,000 مشترك في
اكياف واحده هنتحدث ووجهها كلماته كلماته
الى عمده كيف طالبا بالاصرار في حل هذه
المشكله السلطات الاوكرانيه هنا وبحس بما
نشاهده وهي تسعى لاصال الكهرباء الى جميع
المناطق ولكن ما زال العمل بالنظام
التقنيين ساعات الكهرباء مستمر فيما يتعلق
همم ضربه همم مصادر الطاقه اوكراني كانت
اتهمت في الايام الاخيره